il s'appelle gemini f android ont eu
gemini hi5 ce sont des robots androïdes
conçu pour ressembler le plus fidèlement
possible à des humains selon leurs
créateurs
il pourrait un jour faire partie nos
vies hiroshi ishiguro professeur à
l'université d'osaka
c'est l'un des roboticiens les plus en
vue de la planète
ces recherches touchent à l'ingénierie
l'intelligence artificielle mais aussi à
la psychologie et ou sciences cognitives
[Musique]
son objectif créer des robots dotés
d'intelligence et même d'émotions
son robot le plus célèbre
c'est son jumeau le roboticien l'opère à
distance
mais ce sera ma copie au fil des années
le robot this year version de son double
pas des gemini hi5 il plus récent de la
série
erica est une autre vedette du
laboratoire
elle a été conçue spécifiquement pour
faire la conversation des microphones
cachés dans les plantes en plastique
4 les mots de son interlocuteur l'ine
puis l'intelligence artificielle
lyricale fabrique une réponse ou des
caméras cachées dans les yeux d'eric a
filmé ses interlocuteurs le professeur
croit qu à force de scruter les êtres
humains les robots pourraient apprendre
à me met nos réactions et nos émotions
un autre robot tout récent a été conçu
pour épier les comportements humains
c'est celui d'un enfant
il s'appelle ibuki ses concepteurs dont
le professeur yoshihiro nakamura espère
que les humains étaient réagiront avec
lui plus longuement qu'avec les robots
adultes comerica les défis d'ingénierie
sont nombreux complexe à relever mais le
professeur ishiguro crois qu'un jour les
robots androïdes pourrait devenir nos
compagnons une version rudimentaire et
des chats mise à l'essai dans des
centres pour personnes âgées pour
tromper la solitude des résidents
les robots plus avancés ne seront pas à
la portée de toutes les bourses
ceux qui sont fabriqués dans les
laboratoires du professeur et chez doro
talent entre 100000 et 400 mille dollars
[Musique]